you know how much it costs in terms of  running your overall business every  month the gaming channel we probably are  spending like a couple hundred thousand  a month reacts a couple hundred thousand  a month the main Channel now probably  like three or four million a month  feasibles is spending probably a million  or so a month before same thing  peaceables is about to go into retail  and we just filled like a four million  dollar purchase order so we can buy  enough bars to fill retail we're  probably spending like seven or eight  million dollars I mean even like our  peace our charity I put a lot of money  into that so we can have food and stuff  it's getting pretty crazy